welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and if Kang the Conqueror killed
all the Avengers in some past timeline
when exactly did he kill Captain America
Steve Rogers One crucial detail in
quantumania and one now very Grim detail
in Loki May point to the answer because
it turns out Captain Rogers cannot do
this all day
[Music]
and I will burn them out of time and
this video is brought to you by
Squarespace more on them later this wind
gang killed series is something that
we've been doing here at new Rockstar
since November to pinpoint the precise
moments in the lives of each major MCU
figure that spawned these Nexus events
in which they'd be most vulnerable to
Kang targeting them for pruning like
when they made a specific choice to
alter history on their timeline that
presented a danger to Kang or ruptured
their timeline to create an incursion
which we know came to conqueror it hates
and so next on our list after Thor last
month was Captain America Steve Rogers
cap is obviously a Man Out of Time whose
very existence is defined by being
displaced from its rightful path through
history he already burned himself at a
time or we should say froze himself out
of it but there is one choice that Steve
made that Kang would be like oh yes
right there by the way if you're going
to WonderCon this year I will be doing a
panel with other new Rockstar's hosts on
Friday March 24th at 2 30 room 213 a b
come hang out with us so let's break
down the exact moment Kang killed Steve
Rogers let's start by looping back to
the moment Kang first talked to Scott
Lang in Quantum media I'm an Avenger
have I killed you before
what
they all blow together after a while
you're not the one with the hammer it's
Thor the one with the hammer now I
zeroed in on this line when we discussed
when Kang might have killed Thor and I
do believe it was mjolnir's Final zap
that Frankenstein visioned life in age
Voltron that would be a pretty good
option but let's be real for a second
would Kang have forgotten Thor and
Asgardian God the kind of conqueror from
history and mythology that this Kang in
particular Fashions himself as as I'm
sure you've already realized Thor ain't
the only Avenger who has used mjolnir in
fact if you were to ask most Marvel fans
the most iconic usage of that hammer
would be when it was wielded by Steve
Rogers in Avengers end game the one with
the hammer could have just as likely
referred to Captain America who from
King's Point of View bears at least a
bit more of a resemblance to Scott Lang
in that full body suit the short haircut
their shared Plucky American resilience
Scott Lang and Steve Rogers are kind of
like Sebastian Stan and Richard Madden
squint your eyes at Bucky and Icarus and
it's easy enough to durable mcdill at
them so is this Dylan McDermott or kit
McDermott
you know what F you so would Kang and
prune cap the moment he picked up
mjolnir to fight Thanos to the Battle of
Earth hell no you know Kang was munching
on popcorn watching cap kid the business
to his big bad predecessor Thanos with a
super smash hammer
hey King the Conqueror would have wanted
the Avengers to beat up Thanos I think
that's one thing all Kang variants even
the rivals with each other could agree
upon because we know the TBA and
therefore he remains made an exception
for The Avengers using the time Heights
to reverse the snap and beat Thanos
we're not here to talk about the
Avengers oh no no what they did was
supposed to happen you escaping was not
for all Kings to be powerful they can't
really be competing for power with
Thanos but there was another moment when
cap wielded the hammer that Kang the
Conqueror would have been more sensitive
to in which you could forgive Kang for
mixing them up with Scott Lang the end
of Avengers end game when Steve walked
up on that rebuilt Quantum tunnel
platform suited up in that red and white
Quantum suit carrying in one hand the
briefcase with the Infinity Stones and
in the other the hammer and to go on
this journey cap would have had to go
alone through the quantum rom-time
vortexes wearing a helmeted pimtech
Quantum suit modeled on the ones hang
pin designed for himself and Scott Lang
to navigate the quantum realm isn't it
possible that Kang would have gotten
Ant-Man here make mixed up with that guy
look we're gonna get back to the video
in one second but I gotta tell you about
Squarespace not only are they making it
possible for me to make this video they
could also be making it possible for you
to do honestly whatever you want to do
online that's because Squarespace makes
it easy to make an awesome website that
lets you engage with your audience and
sell anything you need your products the
content you create even your time
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
for building your brand and growing your
business online if you're into making
videos Squarespace can help you create
Pro level videos effortlessly the
Squarespace video studio app will help
you make and share engaging videos to
tell your story grow your audience and
drive sales and hey maybe videos aren't
your thing because you're more of a
social media buff well no problem you
can display posts from any profile you
want on your website and automatically
push website content to your favorite
social media channels so your followers
can share it too no matter what you're
doing squarespace's analytic tools will
help you learn where your traffic and
sales are coming from and so you can
improve your website and build a
marketing strategy based on either your
top keywords or your most popular
products and content head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com new rockstars to save 10
off your first purchase of website or
domain now of course we never saw caps
return journey to put each infinity
stone back in the places in time and
space where they were taken and to
return mjolnator Thor that was all left
off screen and it's been the subject of
much speculation over the past four
years returning the time Stone to the
Ancient One in 2012 the Power Stone in
the orbit to the Morag temple in 2014
and the space Stone tesseracted The
Shield storage in 1970 at Camp Lehigh
that no problem but returning the Mind
Stone scepter to the hands of Hydra in
2012 less admirable but doable but then
reinserting the reality Stone ether to
Jane Foster's body in asgarden 2013.
that's super Shady But ultimately
returning the Soul Stone to Red Skull on
Vermeer how there's obviously a whole
other history that happened with this
guy but this Steve Rogers could not have
been pruned from the infinity Saga
sacred timeline because we saw him
successfully make it to Peggy and we saw
his elderly form after that life with
Peggy make it back to Bucky and Sam
whether you subscribe to the Russo
Brothers interpretation of that ending
so that Steve must have come back to
this timeline from the branch timeline
he formed by staying with Peggy or the
screenwriters Marcus mcfeely's odd take
that this deed continued to live in the
background of this MCU History either
way if old Steve shows up at the end of
end game he could not have gotten pruned
or killed but if we look at the Steve
who walked on that Quantum tunnel
platform who went back in time on that
return Journey not just as one man in
one timeline only doing this but as an
infinite number of Steves across every
timeline now things get interesting the
infinity Saga MCU sacred timeline where
old Steve survives would have been the
only one that came the Conqueror
couldn't touch because it was protected
by he remains in the tva's intact
Clockwork but Steve Rogers is from other
timelines who went back to return the
Infinity Stones in mjolnir not as lucky
because by doing this Steve Rogers
creates a variant branch that just goes
on and on and on never gets pruned
snaking into another reality creating an
incursion old Steve at the end of end
game got away with another crack in the
damn of the Multiverse no wonder why he
didn't want to talk about it fact that
could explain why in episode 1 of Loki
in the background of the TVA we saw a
detained variant who looked a lot like
Peggy Carter that could have been one of
the pruned peggies from one of the other
Steve Rogers who got targeted old Steve
represents the exception he remains made
for the Avengers timeline Shenanigans
and I just don't see Kang the Conqueror
letting every Steve get away with that
now again this confrontation
between Kang and Steve Rogers would have
happened off-screen it's not something
that old Steven endgame had gone through
I'm inviting you to consider another
universe's Steve one who instead of
getting free Passage through the quantum
realm time Vortex is to return
everything this guy's Voyage was
hijacked by Kang the Conqueror who
thanks to the events of Loki was now
freed by Sylvie killing he remains so
Kang and Steve tumble through history
2014 Morag 2014 vort Mir 2013 Asgard
2012 battle in New York an 1870 Camp
Lehigh and then maybe roll punching each
other at Peggy Carter's front doorstep
in the late 40s they're duking it out
cap says I could do this all day Kang
says that's what the last Steve said and
then snaps his neck in front of Peggy
and sends the TBA in to take her away so
I think this need one of his variants
wearing the quantum suit about to dive
into Kang territory the one with the
hammer about to try to get away with a
massive incursion this is the exact
moment that Kang kills cap we have a
whole new channel called The Deep dive
where I do a crazy in-depth analysis of
Loki season 1 and a lot of other pointed
investigations that I think you'll love
so please subscribe to that and support
our growing Network by grabbing
something from the deep dive collection
at nerdright.shop you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at EA boss follow
me rockstars And subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you